so how did that one costume impact the
rest of the work for the revenant I
thought was important for him to look
like a guide somebody who hunted to keep
the men alive and a leader so leo has
power in stature just by his size he's
tall he's got great big broad shoulders
but he also I felt shouldn't look like
quite the mercenary as I made Tom Hardy
its costume to reflect he Tom Hardy was
there not just for survival but for
monetary gain he was in the wilderness
for completely different reasons than
Hugh glass so I wanted his coat to look
a little bit more designed I've used
fringe to with the water is totally
lined in pelts his hat his at the
beginning of the movie he were wears a
piece called an eyepatch to cover his
scar because it was historical that when
anyone was scalped that was a more
seasoned fur trader they were told to
cover their scars so that the young it
wouldn't scare the young recruits to the
fur trade off so it gave him him almost
kind of pirate sinister look at the
beginning later on I added more and more
badger
as he goes towards the fort he's got a
full-on badger down his back otter down
his back and Badgers on the front and I
figure those two animals have totally
figured out the wilderness and survival
and they're very wily and smart and
there was a certain because he's not a
either black or white characters so
they're in the greys doing he's a victim
of his own desire to survive
and it goes awry and it's unintentional
for some part and the other parties just
mean but I wanted that survival of the
fittest in his incorporated into his
coat and then Bridger was young Jim
Bridger how it was reflected in his
wardrobe he's in the movie a lot
he was became having been trained by
Hugh glass about the wilderness he
became the most famous mountain man of
all times there's a fort erected to him
in Montana Jim Bridger became the
definitive mountain man in America and
probably he's the most famous he's the
one all the reenactment people emulate
so I made his coat Buffalo to represent
the Great Plains and having been trained
about the Great Plains by Hugh glass I
aligned it it's it's it's a real Buffalo
skin turned inside out because I thought
that showed you know a certain smartness
wearing the fur on the inside and that
was that was the theory behind him and
then Captain Henry I tried to keep out
of fur as much as they could and keep
his military bearing intact and
fortunately I kind of pounced on the
Museum of the fur trade which this
lovely woman Gail Potter who have known
for several years runs and curates and
she helped me a lot she had a lot of
actual pieces under glass of Henry's
clothing with drawings other men had
done of Captain Henry so she had his
actual leggings leather leggings there
at the Museum of the fur trade in Chad
noon Chadron Nebraska and she let me
copy them and they're under glass
they're from 1823
you